okay now this means that what you're
going to get
up above if we change this angle from pi
on 2 to something else
you're still going to get an arc of some
kind it's just going to be bigger or
smaller
than a semicircle and whether it's
bigger or smaller
depends on the angle that we get and so
that's why on the bottom of the page
here i want you to have a look
right these segments they change
name actually i'll stay with orange they
change name based on whether
they are bigger or smaller than a
semicircle
so if you have a really large segment up
the top
we call that a major segment
okay now have a look at the various
sizes of theta as you go from left to
right even though theta could be
a variety of different angles if that
segment up the top
is a major segment what can you tell me
about the size of theta it's
it's sharp isn't it do you see that so
it's and like our little word for sharp
is
it's an acute angle that's why we say if
you have acute pain
it's a sharp pain right so if you have a
major segment you must
have an acute angle in other words theta
is between
zero and pi on two
now we've already looked at this special
case in the middle
if you have a segment that is exactly
that is is bounded by a diameter right
so in other words if i
am if i'm going through if my uh my
chord there goes through the center
then this is the angle in a semicircle
we saw this before
what angle do you get up there exactly
pi on two so it's a right angle
yeah so you may even like to go ahead
and put a corner up the top there
right like so and our last case over
here on the right hand side
is that if we sort of push that chord up
so that you have a
small segment at the top it's not quite
a small segment by the way
formally the opposite of major is minor
so if you have a minor segment what kind
of angle do you get
you get a an obtuse angle it's very
very wide up there you can see at the
top so it's obtuse
[Music]
now what we've been doing is we've been
thinking about
change the segment right and therefore
you change the angle and that's from pi
on 2
to pi but what we tend to get if you
turn the page over
is actually in reverse order we are
going to get an equation that is
an angle it gives you an angle and you
have to work out are you in a major
segment or a minus segment
will you get a major arc or a minor arc
let's have a look at
these together i'd like us to and this
is just to not worry about any of the
algebra or anything like that right
let's just think about
where this is going to go we want to
construct arcs that will approximately
fit these particular points and these
particular
angles that i've defined for us up here
okay so
first thing and i'll just go to the
previous page so you don't have to flick
back and forth
my angle here is pi on three is it
acute obtuse or right angled it's
it's acute right pi on three that's 60
degrees so are you going to get a major
segment or a minor segment
it's a major segment so small angle
means a big segment
okay so therefore i'm going to be
drawing a big
arc to make my big segment around here
do i start
at the top left or the bottom right
i've labeled them very helpfully for you
i'm going to start the bottom right
because this is z1
and i'm going to go in which direction
anti-clockwise very good so therefore
i'm going to get something going off in
in this direction do you see that i'm
going anti-clockwise and you can see
rather than draw something like this
that's a small that's going to give me a
small segment right
i've gone out to way out to get like a
very large segment right
so i'm just going to do this very
messily for you right you can see i'm
going to go
anti-clockwise
and that that looks really terrible and
messy you you'd be like sort of shading
that in pencil to get the rough shape
and then you say okay that's roughly
where i'm going to go and you can check
this for yourself
by finding a point on the circumference
of the arc you've just drawn
and checking to see does that does that
look like pi on three to you
i mean if you had a protractor with you
could actually measure it but at the
moment
i'm not focusing on the exact like the
precision here i'm not asking for
intercepts or coordinates
i just want you to get the general sense
uh have a look over at two you've got
different points
but do you have an acute or obtuse angle
you've got an acute angle again so
you're gonna get another major segment
i'm gonna pause and let you have an
explore through this page
and see what kind of shapes you get okay
so have a go and then i'll show you my
um
my properly neat ones that i did earlier
on okay off you go
so as you've seen me do before this is
my chef's equivalent of here's one i
prepared earlier um because
it really is quite tricky to draw these
if you i've said this to a few of you
if you have not been drawing with a
pencil um
stop like get a pencil okay borrow a
pencil um you desperately need one
i did that's right um so so a cautionary
tale over there thank you mr
axinski what i want you to notice is and
when you have a look at my
arcs right the first thing is you can
clearly see where you get major arcs and
minor arcs
major arcs and minor arcs and they are
matched up
with acute angles and obtuse angles
respectively
right small angle big arc i want you to
notice for example when you look at my
pi on 3 my pi on 4
you can see my arc is bigger for my pi
on 4 right that's because a smaller
angle
will give you a bigger arc if you took
the limit as theta approaches 0
you are getting closer and closer and
closer to a circle
right because if you were having like an
angle like that you'd have to go all the
way around the circle
to create that angle now i also want you
to notice
actually sort of a tricky sneaky thing
which will help you but i haven't talked
about it because we didn't have the time
one of the circle properties which you
may have encountered at the end of year
10 but there's a good chance you didn't
is that if you are and put this onto
your diagram right now by the way
if you are to draw a chord um that
has that that interval right and if you
were to take
to go back to what we had a look at last
lesson
the perpendicular bisector of that chord
so um
that looks okay to me there so what i've
done
is a perpendicular bisector so i've
sliced my chord
in half and i've done it roughly at
right angles anyway
the perpendicular bisector of a chord
will always pass through
the center of a circle so you can know
if you're roughly in the right spot or
if your circle is like gone lopsided
if that doesn't look anywhere near the
center of the circle that your arc is a
part of
okay so line from the center bisects
the chord at right angles so then the
other thing i want you to notice is
again because i radically distrust
myself is that you notice i put those
arrows on
those arrows along each of the arcs why
do you think i've done that
what's that about yeah it's for me to
make sure did i do this anti-clockwise
or not right
and so that you don't have to put those
arrows on but for me it's just a check
i'm like yep no i got it headed in the
right direction so i can be confident
i'm showing you guys
the right solution okay now i'm going to
pause
there you've got two things that i want
you to do with the
20 minutes that we have left number one
as usual there are tasks assigned
on canvas and you can work on with those
but
the next direction from here is we've
all been quite vague on here right like
i deliberately gave you no coordinates
just so you would focus on the shape
once you have a look at the top right
hand corner of the board there i ninja
it onto the board in the
red there that's an equation that will
give you an arc
right and this time i've given you
coordinates and i'll give you an exact
angle and i'd like you to this time try
and work out
the cartesian equation and like
intercepts and the center and all that
kind of thing
of that particular arc i've tried to
make it relatively nice and neat for you
so it's not awkward and off at a funny
angle
you should be able to work it out with
some geometric reasoning i'd advise you
maybe start there
and then go to the exercise